tonight on Brian Ross investigates a
shout-out special for some amazing
investigative journalism exposing a
thriving sex trafficking ring in
Minnesota the more we dug into it the
more we started finding reports that
Minnesota here in the middle of the
country on some major highways is in
some cases ground zero for sex
trafficking in Iowa a small-town
newspaper puts its future on the line to
reveal the relationship of a local
police officer and a teenage girl if you
can't stand up for a vulnerable teenage
girl that I don't think you have any
business standing near a printing press
the reporters in Puerto Rico whose
investigations brought down the governor
we never expected something like this
would have would happen we just thought
that there were so many things wrong
with the governor and the brave
journalist in Ukraine who stood up to
both Russia and to her own government
honest journalism is the best form of
patriotism
from the law and crime Network Studios
in New York City's Herald Square this is
Brian Ross investigates and good evening
and welcome tonight a shout out encore
special a salute to local journalists
around the country and overseas making
their world's a better place with
powerful investigative reporting
beginning with reporters at a television
station in Minnesota who uncovered a
startling problem made worse by local
judges this investigation started
because we get a Super Bowl here in
Minnesota in 2018 and with that Super
Bowl there was a lot of talk about sex
trafficking so our investigative unit
really wanted to go deeper on this
subject a jail ago and his team at kare
11 TV in Minneapolis st. Paul soon
uncovered a shocking reality that had
remained well the more we dug into it
the more we started finding reports that
Minnesota here in the middle of the
country on some major highways is in
some cases Brownsboro for sex
trafficking and passing through going to
oil field
Toto or crossing from you know important
Duluth that has big ships coming in
heading down to Chicago and you know
some of your other cities through the
heart of so that must have been quite a
surprise for your viewers certainly I
think it really was I bet you there was
a lot of really our backyard kinda
questions that pop up we started
exposing and they brought the story to
life with a focus on one 16 year old
girl who they called jodel this is the
police car camera tape of that young
girl being rescued she and her friend
had run away from home in Duluth and
fell into the hands of two men who began
to sell them the girls were taken to
this st. Paul motel room two to nine is
where Joe Dells he'll be
I had a knife put up to my neck when I
was being raped yes poignant interviews
especially with a young lady who was
willing to share some really horrific
details of what happened to her and her
experience to showcase why this was such
a problem and how did you get those
incredible police tapes of her and she
was expressing her fear of what was
going on really that took more work than
just about anything else in this
investigation because the police were
understandably loath to release those
eventually ended up working with the
victim did she allowed us to share them
and in some of the other police videos
it was really just identifying key cases
that had no made headlines across the
state you know in the months and years
prior but hadn't really been delved into
and are really with a really serious
spot but what took this investigative
reporting to a higher level was what
Lego and his team discovered in area
courts once the men responsible were
brought to justice
huge numbers able to avoid what was
supposed to be a mandatory financial
fine with the money used to help victims
when we analyzed seven years of
statewide court data we found from 2011
to 2017 there were 196 traffickers
sentenced but 118 of them 60% had no
prostitution assessment imposed and the
more we kept pulling that string
initially we found okay judges aren't
imposing these fines that are supposed
to be mandatory and shortchanging
victims of sex trafficking
then we flip it on its head and we said
okay what's happening with the money
when judges actually do impose and when
we did that he found that the money that
was by loss supposed to be going for
very specific things taking care of
things police prosecution just for
training handled these case the money
was missing misplaced misused it was
going into general funds and it wasn't
he used the way the law required so we
found that and we kept digging on that
and then we found since okay so we found
money going directly into a pocket is a
bonus getting convict
which was maybe the most shocking thing
we found and when the kare 11 team
sought reaction from the judges not a
single judge in the state would talk
with us including the judge who handled
the case involving 16 year old Joe tell
whose abusers were convicted but not
required to pay the mandatory fine we
email judge Merrick asking why the
failure to find she refused to be
interviewed responding
I do not comment on my cases nor on my
decision-making process it's the kind of
work that does not come easily or
quickly this story took months to
prepare before it ever went on-air we're
juggling other projects at the same time
but I spent weeks just being a records
room reading through cases you know
understanding how sex trafficking cases
work hit our judicial system our unit
has myself it has producer Steve
accurate who I know you know from his
Dateline days what do you say to those
stations that aren't doing this kind of
work with that kind of investment in
backing you need to give your crews time
to do this kind of journalism because
this is what our job is it's the hold
people accountable as to shine a light
in places you're not going to be able to
you know and to help end a culture that
has for too long tolerated cases like
that of Joe Dell next in Iowa Newspaper
which also sought to protect vulnerable
children reporting on a local police
officer involved with a teenage girl a
story that threatened to put the paper
out of business the community is about
10,000 people we we we cover a Carol and
a pretty broad surrounding area so we
try to be neither the common scold or
the blind booster the Carol Times Herald
in Carroll Iowa was founded by Douglas
burns grandfather some 90 years ago
Burns is the infant in this photo and
the pictures on his editor's wall tell a
story of a local newspaper with great
ambitions
this was burns in the Oval Office after
an interview with President Obama with
the advent of the the Trump
administration and some of the fake news
tropes I know our journalism is
appreciated and we do a lot of it but
the cost of doing those stories can be
high as Burns discovered in a story
about this Carroll Police Officer Jacob
Smith that began with the tip that Smith
was having a sexual relationship with a
teenage girl in Iowa the age of consent
is 16 so there there was nothing with
that relationship but we thought it was
the kind of involvement an activity by a
police officer that the community should
know about and that you know most most
parents would would find find that kind
of would find it very concerning so we
worked on the story if you've read it
it's it's it's thoroughly reported and
the reporter that wrote it is very
experienced the we we didn't you know we
we vetted it as closely and as carefully
as any Brian as any story that that
we've ever published officer Smith
resigned even before the story was
published and then filed a lawsuit
against the Times Herald so I had never
been sued before and I wouldn't suggest
people add it to their bucket list in
the lawsuit Smith alleged his reputation
has been destroyed his character and
integrity forever castigated in the
public eye and his employability as a
law officer severely damaged if not
totally ruined and when you begin your
defense did you consider a retraction or
correction to get rid of the lawsuit we
did not because we felt that we had the
story and that if we would if we would
surrender on this Brian that it would
have a chilling effect on not just other
media but particularly other small media
in Iowa uh that that we you know if we
if we caved on it for financial
expediency which I was given an
opportunity to do that in the end the
judge dismissed the case finding the
article at issue
accurate and true and the underlying
facts are undisputed
buttburn says it took a year and more
than $100,000 in legal fees to get that
result that I knew full well that had we
lost the case my career would have been
over then and you know we would have had
to you know sell the paper then for
either financial reasons or credibility
reasons
and now Byrne says he's been forced to
ask for outside financial help in an
unusual move posting a GoFundMe page
seeking $140,000 to cover all the
expenses that came out of the lawsuit if
you can't stand up for a vulnerable
teenage girl that I don't think you have
any business standing near a printing
press so this was the proverbial hill
you're willing to die on and you know I
even in doing this interview now and
doing this conversation for him being
involved in these conversations
you know I've trepidation that that
because of the spotlight being drawn on
this case again that you know it could
it could still hurt us at this point any
regrets at all about the decision you
made two runs of story
and to stand up to the lawsuit I don't
think I got to live with myself if I you
know if we hadn't pursued hadn't pursued
the story it was the right thing to do
this is why local ownership matters
because this is this is my community I
live here I am I'm on the Library
Foundation I helped start the Carroll
High School Foundation
I care deeply about this town and I
don't want this kind of behavior
occurring here as of this week the Gulf
fund me page has received almost
$100,000 enough to keep going but
certainly not with any frills I my
salary right now is under $30,000 a year
to keep the paper going so there's
there's not gonna be any trips in the
future any you're not gonna have to come
out here and do an investigative piece
about how the money's being used because
it's it's going right back into into
journalism putting good journalism ahead
of profits when we return the small team
of investigative journalists whose work
brought down a governor
back now with our shout out encore
special recognizing some great
investigative journalism including a
small band of intrepid reporters in
Puerto Rico who's worked helped to bring
about the resignation of the islands
governor when more than a hundred
thousand people took to the streets in
San Juan Puerto Rico this summer
demanding the ouster of the governor and
other local officials it was the direct
result of the work of a small team of
investigative reporters at Puerto Rico's
center for investigative journalism led
by executive director Carla Burnett we
were definitely we never expected
something like this would have would
happen we just thought that there were
so many things wrong with the governor
and his closest advisors and officials
that we thought that everybody had to
know how they were talking who they were
talking about and what was the tone that
they were using and it all came in an
almost 900 page transcript of an online
messaging a chat it's called between the
governor and his closest associates and
advisors documents turned over by a
confidential source the governor called
one rival a whore he wrote about another
we must liquidate him today
one of the governor's deputies brought
about a frequent critic of the governor
I am salivating to shoot her you you
would never expect something like that
from a government official about their
own political party a lies about the
poor people of women about LGBT
community about everyone you know you
wouldn't expect that just to say it in
black and white it was awful it must
have been amazing to see it right there
in front of you it was it was we were
speechless
their story came as the people of Puerto
Rico were still trying to recover from
two devastating hurricanes and the snide
comments from the governor and his
cronies Minette
says proved to be a kind of tipping
point in the public outrage they just in
general they they talk in a very
disrespectful way about the victims and
I think that hurt many people you know
everybody here in Puerto Rico went
through a lot because of the hurricane a
former top aide of the governor wrote
about the growing problem with dead
bodies quote now that we are on the
subject don't we have some cadavers to
feed our crows within days of the
group's publication of the governor's
chats the crowds began to form on the
streets of San Juan leading to some
violent confrontations tear gas was
first deployed by police around 11:00
p.m. and that sent protesters running at
first governor Ricardo was shallow said
he had no intention of stepping down
there are a hundred thousand people on
the streets politicians of all stripes
the President of the United States all
saying you need to go that this is
enough you've said no why not well
there's there's an important component
about rule of law and democracy and I
respect that process but the protest
continued fueled by the ongoing
reporting of the Center for
Investigative Journalism and then siento
que continúa en la posición after hours
of delay Roe say you'll finally said the
words these people had been waiting 12
days to hear I will be resigning
[Applause]
I have to say I was not surprised
everybody expected that to happen we
were expecting that to happen because he
had no other choice
but when it happened did you feel like
oh my goodness we caused this well you
know I don't see it as we caused this I
see it like us the people did their part
you know we do so many stories that
never have this kind of outcome so I
think it was it was the people's doing
what happened in the end you know we are
also citizens we have families we live
here and of course we are concerned
about the outcomes of this process but
we feel that socially it has been a
great lesson for everyone in Puerto Rico
and also for other countries and for
other states and territories a lesson
about the power of the press yeah
definitely the power of the press and
the power of the people when we come
back a shout out for an investigative
reporter who took on Russia and her own
government
we continue now with our special shout
out for reporters taking on the risks
that are inherent with investigative
reporting and nowhere is that more true
that in places not protected by the
American First Amendment like Ukraine
nastiest acos career in journalism has
already seen her called a hero
a traitor and a liar she's been on the
frontlines of war been threatened with
death been held hostage confronted both
Moscow and her own government in Kiev
all of that at the age of 33 given all
the pressure and given the threats and
the danger hmm you still want to be a
journalist given everything you know
when you live in such country as Ukraine
it's always you always you know have
this feeling that it's not boring it's
can be boring now the deputy
editor-in-chief of the Ukraine
television station she helped to found
stock Oh says she chose journalism as a
teenager after seeing reports of a
television camera man for Reuters killed
in Iraq by US forces which claimed his
camera looked like a weapon it was 2003
yes I remember and I saw it's very
important to be such an dangerous places
and say the people truth from such
dangerous place and places and I said I
want to be younger and she did not have
to travel far to find a war to cover it
came to her when Russian back forces
turned parts of Ukraine into a war zone
hot spot five years ago and then she was
taken hostage by the Russian back forces
they took me to this basement with
something in my hat I mean it's just
like some coat because that I shouldn't
see nothing well where are we going and
of course they said that maybe they will
cut my hat something like this
when Nastya was released after a few
days she was hailed as a hero for her
courage under such trying circumstances
but then a few years later when she
produced this report documenting how
Ukraine's own security services have
their own secret prisons the same people
who had called her our hero now said she
was a traitor giving the Russians
ammunition to criticize the Ukrainian
government the people of Ukraine should
know that it happened maybe it's not ok
because it's illegal you know and I when
we this true can help I think it's just
ridiculous Stanko and her reporting team
tracked down people who had been held in
the secret compounds who identified key
details of the cells where they were
held and some of the people who served
as their guards and thence tackle
confronted the top officials who had
earlier denied the existence of any such
secret prisons you see this is 10 people
telling outright lies to the
international organization because they
were recruited by for example the
Russian Federation
now with Ukraine at the center of
attempts in the US Congress to impeach
president Donald Trump stucco has
another big story on her hands you know
and it's very scary but Sacco says it's
no time to ease up even as she faces new
criticism that her reporting will only
weaken the Ukrainian president and
helped the Russians this is how stucco
put it when she was honored by the
Committee to Protect Journalists with
their international Press Freedom Award
it's difficult to walk when you are
expected to choose between majorities
and professional journalism standing
here in front of my colleagues from all
around the world I know this pressure is
not something only we Ukrainians feel
it's pressure experienced by anyone who
chooses journalism in their profession
but I also know that there is no need to
choose honest journalism in the best
form of patriotism in an error of
government corruption corporate this
conduct and the abuse of power those
words spoken by a journalist whose
colleagues have faced threats of
imprisonment and death those are the
perfect words to end this special
shout-out report and that's our program
for tonight thanks so much for joining
us we'll see you back here next week